à la liberté de presse et à la
liberté d'expression des Russes.
ELENA VOLOCHINE correspondante
à Moscou pour France 24
- Pour la première fois,
moi en tout cas ça fnsnsnsnsns
que je travaille Russie.
J'ai toujours obéi aux règles,
j'ai toujours travaillé avec
une station, voilà, j'ai
toujours respecté les règles
du jeu. C'est les règles quand
on travaille dans un pays quia s
celles d'un pays démocratique,
mais là, j'ai senti que
clairement le vent tournait
et que on allait être empêché
de travailler.
- Par ailleurs Justin Trudeau se
rendra en Europe la semaine
prochaine.
- La semaine prochaine, ce sera
le marathon des réunions
bilatérales parce que l'agenda
est très chargé. Je vous donne
l'itinéraire. Dimanche, premier
ministre va s'envoler vers
Londres où il va rencontrer son
brbrbrbrbrbritannique Boris
Johnson ainsi que le premier
traité Pays-Bas et il y aura une
audience avec la reine Élisabeth
: après le Royaume-Uni, il va se
rendre en Lettonie, en Allemagne
et en Pologne. Évidemment, c'est
le conflit en Ukraine qui va
mobiliser les conversationsparcx
vont faire front commun contre
la Russie. On peut écouter le
premier ministre Trudeau.
Pendant ce temps,.. eninininini.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
u u u u u u u que la coordinatin
entre les différents pays,
les démocraties de l'Occident,
en matière de sanctions
et de pénalités pour
la Russie, pour Poutine,
a été extraordinaire.
La semaine p
je vais pouvoir continuer
cette coordination
directement avec nos alliés.
Et en terminant, je vous préci